Hello guys. Welcome to FriDiary!
My name is Grace Helbig
if you didn't know.
Now you do know.
And if you also didn't know,
FriDiary is a look back at my week in a vlog diary form.
So let's look back on some of the things that have happened to me this week!
Grace: Here they come, here they come, here they come...
People: Surprise!
What! *laughing*
What in tarnation!
Good morning, FriDiary.
It is Monday
and it's a really pretty day in Los Angeles.
I am headed to the dentist!
Again. Yayyyy.
They gave me a crown on the back of one of my cavities..
and it's real sensitive.
And I can't chew food on that side.
So, I'm gonna get that checked out
I think they're actually gonna clean my teeth.
Which is exciting.
I forgot to film this but..
don't worry guys. Dentist appointment went great.
Oh, hello FriDiary.
It is still Monday.
It's my night.
And this is happening
*burp*
Excuse me.
Hopefully you will see this video on Thursday..
This is my favorite emoji.
And I tried to do a make-up tutorial for it.
And it was so difficult to do.
I'm not some weird robot cosplay Minnie Mouse.
I can't--I can't keep doing this.
Uh, yup.
That describes Tuesday.
It is Tuesday. Happy Tuesday, FriDiary.
I wear this shirt every day.
Apparently and my hair like this every day.
I'm slowly becoming--*GPS voice* turn left.
Okay.
I'm slowly becoming actual cartoon character.
Life goals!
I've had two meetings this morning.
Really fun.
Actually really great meetings.
Uh, just a lot of driving to get to meetings.
And I was like 25 minutes late to my first meeting.
Because I assume I can get everywhere in 20 minutes
and it's not true.
We've had this conversation before..
Again, future Grace..
editing this clip. You cannot get everywhere in 20 minutes!
But now....
*laughing*
Did I finally just hit puberty?
Uh, I'm gonna shoot a collab video
with Alexis G. Zall right now
I'm driving over to her place..
and I'm excited because fun fact..
for those of the *gibberish*
for those of you who do not know
Alexis G. Zall was an extra in Camp Takota.
She was one of the campers.
And so, she's got a really funny YouTube channel
and we're gonna go make some videos together.
And after that, I have one more meeting.
And then I'm going to--*GPS voice* In a quarter of a mile, turn left..
Hey.
Hi, look who it is.
Alexis G. Zall!
That's me! Hi--
What does the G stand for?
Uh, it's my middle name. Genevieve.
Ohhh.
Just shot a couple videos
and I think they're gonna be really funny
Me, too.
So hopefully you guys like them..
in the near distant future when they hit the interwaves.
Yeah, that was--
Get excited!
Get really excited.
*laughing*
Great content! Woohoo!
*Chopped on TV*
Grace: Ryan!
Hello, guys. Happy Wednesday.
We are currently on our way to @Midnight!
We're gonna go do @Midnight..
and the other contestants on @Midnight are
Nikki Limo!
Which is really exciting.
And Michelle Wolf.
Who is a Late Night writer..
and is someone that I did improv comedy with like
six years ago? Five, four years ago?
Something like that.
So it's all very exciting.
By the time this video goes up,
you will probably know the outcome of the show
But let's go do it.
*mystical iMovie music*
Okay. Hi FriDiary.
Happy Thursday!
It is..Thursday..
And I only vlog in my car apparently..
uh..
today's been a busy day.
I've had a few meetings all day today.
And I have..
lost my mind.
My mind is gone.
It has disintegrated because that can happen
Science doesn't tell you those things.
I am onto my last meeting of the day today.
And then I am doing a show tonight--
*GPS voice* in a mile, turn left.
That was just rude..
but very helpful, so I cannot hate you.
I'm actually doing a show tonight.
At the NerdMelt showroom..
uh, the theater owned by Chris Hardwick..
It's a show called "Risk".
With Kevin Allison, who is my very first ever
sketch comedy writing instructor..
teacher at the People's Improv Theater back in like
2006.
And he's been--*GPS voice* turn left
Thank you.
And he's been doing this show
in New York and brought it to Los Angeles..
and it's a really fun storytelling show slash podcast.
Every month there's a theme
*GPS interrupts again*
My god.
Every month they have a theme and..
they bring a bunch of storytellers..
and a bunch of people to tell their stories based on the theme.
This month's theme is eek!
Feels very appropriate.
*GPS interrupts* My god!!
I will!
So we're gonna go do that..
after this last meeting.
That's it.
Cool chat.
Great times.
*GPS interrupts* OH MY GOD
I forgot to film the show..
but don't worry guys. The show went great.
Hi FriDiary.
Happy actual Friday.
This morning I got my hair did-id-id-id-id
by Wendy J. Diaz!
Look! Roots are clean.
I feel like a brand new robot.
Right now I am headed to Rhett and Link's studio..
to shoot an episode of Good Mythical Morning with them..
and I'm very excited.
Because I have never done that before. Um.
And I love Good Mythical Morning
and so I'm--and I love their new studio.
So...if math serves me correctly,
I should love this experience that's about to happen.
*mystical iMovie music again*
And this happens on Friday night.
Netflix and chill..*record scratch*
No.
Hi FriDiary
It is indeed Friday.
Yeah..got turnt.
Onto her side. She was on the other side and then she turned over.
TURNT.
I just went for a run.
Because I felt stressed out..
and that de-stresses me..
that's why I'm sweaty and gross.
But today one, Wendy J. Diaz
did my hair. Yay.
Then she also
got a gift for Goose..
my dog that's just laying on the couch.
She got her
a Halloween costume.
Look at this.
Frida Kahlo?
Oh my god it's a little dress.
And she made her a flower crown to wear.
Made her!
If Goose wasn't so tired, I would put it on her.
But with Halloween and costumes being on everyone's brains..
here's a quick way to look like the living dead.
I--while I was running got a really stupid genius idea
for a last minute Halloween costume.
If you are maybe a dog owner or doll owner,
and really don't have any other prospects going for ya.
Here's this last minute Halloween costume.
Watch this.
This is maybe like the worst angle to do this at but..
it's happening.
So the first thing you need..
is some long piece of cardboard or maybe um,
like a hockey stick or a piece of wood
or like a couple of paper tower rolls taped together
Just something long that you could tape other things to..
This was in my garbage.
Next, ideally you would need six Barbie dolls..
if you have them but if you don't have them that's fine.
You just need like six dolls.
Or I'm using some dog toys.
Just six.
Together.
Get creative!
Basket of dog toys.
3..
4..
5..
6..
And then you need some sort of tape to secure all of them across the board.
But you wanna leave a decent amount of space in the middle.
So three on each side.
I'm using duct tape.
*festive iMovie music*
Ideally you would want them all in some sort of black..
or dark clothing attire.
But sometimes you just have to work with what you have.
And really hope most of the people at your Halloween party are colorblind.
*festive iMovie music again*
Okay.
Now to fasten it to yourself.
There's probably many better ways to do this but..
this is what I can think of.
Take a backpack if you have it.
And you're gonna slide this blank part of it.
Inside the backpack so that all the dolls face the straps of your backpack.
And then you're gonna tape the backpack closed.
*festive iMusic plays again again*
And then just slide the backpack on.
Oh no. Excuse me.
And then ideally you would be wearing dark clothes.
Maybe like a dark wig.
Um, but there you go. There you have your costume.
Let me put it into full effect so you understand what it is.
♫♫♫ Taylor Swift's "Bad Blood" ♫♫♫
Imagine if they were wearing black clothes and imagine if I actually looked
like a clean version of Taylor Swift.
Easy last minute Halloween costume, you guys.
So..
And today look what came in the mail!
Da dada da!
Nerdy Nummies!
Rosanna
Rosanna Pansino's new cookbook.
It came with a really sweet note.
And this spatula!
Super cute cookbook that you guys should check out.
If you haven't already--and also one of my favorite videos
is the drunk kitchen that she did with this human being..
Hannah Hart.
If you haven't seen that, you have not lived your best life.
So highly recommend.
Other than that, what is happening? Um.
Mamrie Hart and I are doing a show at StreamCon next weekend in New York City.
October 30th. If you in and around the city, you should definitely come.
There's information down below.
Here's a sneak peak. *Lion King plays*
Yeah.
Wow, I know.
And leave a comment down below what you're being for Halloween.
And don't forget to like this video cause that makes me happy.
Feelings.
You can do whatever you want. Honestly what makes me happy is when you are happy.
And you're probably happy doing whatever you want. So do whatever you want.
Within reason..
without harming anyone else..
I don't know.
♫♫♫ Taylor Swfit's "Bad Blood" ♫♫♫